This is a bill that I put forward that would lay the framework for America to lead in the area of quantum computing.
I mean, we are at the precipice of something huge that's going to transform all the way things operate.
I mean, AI and quantum computing to follow.
I mean, this is the next level.
And we're in a moon race with the Chinese right now.
Whoever has AI and quantum supremacy will be the world superpower.
And a lot of the negative information you see out there didn't sprout up by accident.
You notice how all the negativity that's just popped out of nowhere all over social media?
There is a Chinese disinformation campaign coming down in this country and we don't even know it.
It's being funded because they don't want America to compete.
They want to beat us from within.
But we need a framework in place to make sure we're ready.
And that's what the Quantum Computing Act is about because we have to lead and you have to be prepared to lead.
So it's in the jurisdiction of my committee, which is the Energy and Commerce Committee.
We've got the broadest jurisdiction on any committee in Congress.
We have all the technology, telecommunications, healthcare, and energy policy.
Only a couple of big things.
They're going to break that up a little bit?
It keeps me pretty busy and I get to read a lot.
But you also get the most fascinating meetings in the people that come to Washington and I go to them that are really,
I mean, just the breakthroughs that we're on the cusp of in terms of medicine, Alzheimer's disease, pancreatic cancer.
I mean, a lot of that's being brought to us with the help of AI.
You know, when you take 100 million medical data points and run them against each other to try to crack the code and find the solution of what's going to work.
It doesn't replace the doctors and the researchers, but it gives them a tool that they've never had.
And we can save a lot of lives with this.
And to your point, if we're behind the eight ball on this, where does it lead?
It leads to the Chinese being the supremacy in the world.
And we can't afford that.